madame monsieur bonsoir le procès en
révision de patrick dils s'est achevée
par un dernier coup de théâtre la cour
d'assises pour mineurs de la marne l'a
condamné à 25 ans de réclusion
criminelle pour le meurtre des deux
enfants de montigny-lès-metz commis en
86 après six heures de délibéré les
jurés n'ont pas suivi l'avocat général
qui avait demandé l'acquittement sur ce
procès extraordinaire le compte-rendu
l'analyse de notre envoyé spécial
dominique verdeilhan un verdict rendu
dans un silence pesant les jurés ne
regardait pas l'accusé et tout a basculé
au moment le président a annoncé qu'à la
question sur la culpabilité de patrick
dils la cour d'assises avait répondu oui
patrick dils était à nouveau reconnus
coupables patrick dils était à nouveau
condamné pour double meurtre
étonnant patrick 10 qui n'a pas bronché
à l'énoncé du verdict il s'est levé il a
quitté le son box la salle d'audience
sans même se retourner vers la salle
vers le public vers sa mère qui s'était
effondré
quelques minutes plus tôt alors après ce
verdict force est de constater que
révision ne veut pas dire forcément
innocence ne veut pas dire forcément
acquittement malgré la présence supposée
sur les lieux du crime de francis
heaulme
malgré une accusation qui avait requis
l'acquittement
patrick dils a été condamné à 25 ans de
réclusion criminelle
l'excusé de minorité qui aurait permis
une peine de vingt ans lui a été refusé
pourquoi 25 ans difficile de le dire en
tout cas après 14 ans de détention
provisoire patrick dils est en droit de
demander une libération conditionnelle
ses avocats s'interrogent sur
l'opportunité de faire appel de ce
verdict il n'y aura donc peut-être pas
de troisième procès de patrick dils